From feet and urine to servitude and other lifeless objects such as leather,
Have people all kinds of interesting sexual desires and magic.
But is it normalized by non-living objects or non-genital body parts?
Within the brain, which you find sexy is a combination of cognitive, emotional and physical processes.
Of course, the private aspect of sexual behavior has made the study of magic challenging.
To overcome this barrier,
has used a study of online Yahoo groups to estimate the relative frequency of atypical sexual preferences.
Evaluating 5000 internet users,
researchers have discovered that the greatest number of flavors was not just body parts,
but from objects related to body parts such as shoes or earphones.
Popular groups include body fluids and body size
but the most popular group was by far the feet and the toes.
This is because there is actually a neurological basis for foot desires.
Looking at this visual map showing which areas and proportions of the brain are dedicated to the processing of sensory functions,
we see the feet, toes and genitals
everyone is physically right next to each other in the brain.
One study was able to eliminate this link between
sexual desires and brain regions with the man experiencing epileptic seizures as well as a fetish for hook pins.
After receiving a partial temporal lobectomy, or removing part of his brain,
stopped both his attacks and sexual fixation on hooks.
Sexual fantasies are likely to develop during early experiences cedar, when more synapses and neurogenesis occur in your brain.
Sexual imprinting is the process in which we and other animals
learn about the characteristics of desired breeders at a young age,
often influenced by those who raised us.
One study found that adopted girls prefer men with a significant resemblance to facial features of their adopted fathers.
Women who report having a more supportive, emotional relationship with their fathers,
was also more likely to choose men with similar characteristics to those who had negative relationships with their fathers.
But with sexual sorrows, this sexual imprint can also be with objects.
A study with two groups of sexually naive laboratory rats carried one group a small Velcro jacket during their first sexual experience
while the other group, the governing body, wore nothing.
When sexually mature, the control group showed a normal copulation behavior, regardless of whether the jacket was worn or not.
while the jacket group was unable to achieve sexual arousal without their jackets.
The same study was done with other objects and found similar results.
This can explain why a person with learning fetish struggles to experience pleasure without.
In a separate study on rats, a group of male rat infants on bedding was flavored with lemon.
and letting the other group lie on unleavened bedding.
For their first sexual experience,
they had the option of two sexually receptive females,
one flavored with lemon and one without flavor.
The control group paired with both females at a normal frequency
while the lemon learned group of lemon preferred fragrant females.
But these particular desires or preferences can be blocked by a naloxone that blocks endorphins, or the feeling-good neurosender, to bind to the opioid receptors in the brain,
thus blocking the sexual reward that the velcro jacket or the smell of lemons writes.
Although we know a lot about rat sexual magic, there is not much research on scarce sexual preferences in humans.
In the past, they were often listed as mental illnesses.
But while your specific sexual desires and sexual magic can be unique to you and your experience,
proving modern science to have one in the first place is a normal part of man.
And if it doesn't harm you or anyone else, they can exist as part of a healthy sex life.
See our new "I'm gay for science" shirts available for the next two weeks just for all our queer science lovers and LGBTQ allies.
You can use the links in the description to get the shirt in various designs or even to get it as a cup.
Get it before it is cedar there is a limited amount.
Thanks again forever for supporting our channel and helping our little corner of science to flourish.
And write in for more weekly science videos every Thursday.